I put my whole life a guy that would
steer the [ __ ] water a guy that could
[ __ ] tongues I've had a reader right
on being one of the hardest
[ __ ] on the plant think about
that [ __ ] a guy that came from nothing I
put my whole life and I'm gonna go out
here and put everything on David [ __ ]
ganas to be a Navy SEAL not to go be a
[ __ ] you know Boy Scout or some [ __ ]
a Navy SEAL and I and I look at that and
I did all this [ __ ] just to get the
opportunity to succeed that's what
that's what people don't [ __ ]
understand man and people see that the
end result I remember that guy say my
god man I can't believe what the [ __ ]
I've just done I put everything ruin
relationships ruin this ruin that put
everything on fact I have to become
someone in this world or I'm no good for
anybody
weird and where does that come from that
where did that composing that drive it
comes from a disgusting place of not
being fulfilled in your life of afraid
of dying having never accomplished
anything that's the fear that some
people run away from that people don't
want to face when you have a real fear
of dying and being just another person
that I live to pay the bills I made a
thousand dollars a month this is my life
I spray for cockroaches man if if that
makes you feel good that's great
it didn't make me feel good I wanted to
the first time my life after 26 years as
24 25 wherever I was I wanted to feel
good about myself and that was that was
the ticket yeah I mean you have this
huge reservoir this capacity to leverage
pain and circumstance to drive change
within yourself right to be able to not
be a victim but to look at pain as your
friend as a catalyst for growth and I
think there's a lot of people out there
look if you're in a enough pain that's
gonna move the needle for you there's a
lot of people out there that are in
just enough pain where they're willing
to just settle for what they have
because they're not in enough pain to
change and the fear of change outweighs
the pain of their daily existence you
know the one gift I have with all that
being said what you just said there is I
have the ability to see the end before
the beginning even begins and what that
means is I know that to get to the very
end
I can see it right now so before with
the buds and I was losing on the [ __ ]
waiting [ __ ]
I saw myself walking across the [ __ ]
stage at 191 [ __ ] pounds guys I had
to get to get into the door I saw myself
six months a year later whatever's gonna
take me to do I saw myself walking
across that stage getting that [ __ ]
certificate of graduation from buds and
I was able to be there at 300 [ __ ]
pounds and that feeling that I was
nowhere near that [ __ ] feeling I was
able to put myself there a million times
every [ __ ] day and that feeling of
like oh my god that is gonna feel
[ __ ] amazing that's what made me
suffer that's what allowed the pain to
be realistic this is worth it I want to
feel for this [ __ ] next 18 months
could take me 18 [ __ ] months to
finally come in a v60 find me you know
just get new butts 18 months is six
months took me 18 that's what woke me up
every [ __ ] morning was I don't put
myself through this much [ __ ] pain
and suffering for a few seconds so it is
a few seconds of joy is so [ __ ] worth
it man and so people don't get so I'm
able to put myself at the finish line
you know I have no finish line but at
the finish line of an event before I
even start the [ __ ] to say how
are you gonna fill it into this well
visualization is one of the challenges
and part of that is not just visualizing
success or living in the reality of
achieving what you're setting out to
achieve but also visualizing how you're
going to navigate all the obstacles that
are gonna get thrown in your path right
visualizing this is my biggest tool of
life that's why I've been able to put
myself in Coldwater put myself in a
hundred
race millions of times before I've done
it and I'm able to go through the race
and see I'm gonna feel at Mile 50 almost
to the almost to the exact Zac feeling
right so when it comes up it's no
surprise no surprise I've already done
this at many times and that's the one
thing I practice in practice and
practice and practice overnight but also
the most important thing is I practiced
that feeling of accomplishment I'm gonna
have more sauce and done with the crazy
thing about the a swaps to hurry is that
in addition to having to pass this test
and get that 50 you also have to lose
100 pounds and like what like 30 days or
some creatures it was less than three
months
right okay three months so but you
compartmentalize these two tasks and say
look the first thing I got to do is I
got to pass this test right because the
weight doesn't matter if I don't get
that 50 and you shelved or put off
losing the weight to focus on the
academic end of it until you you know
completed that hurdle and then you
looked at the weight stuff I'm like that
now that I've done yeah it's like being
focused on one thing at a time I have to
be very present in everything I do like
right now I'm with which role I'm not
thinking about [ __ ] but rich role and
what the fuss coming out of your mouth
right now
that's what that's what gives me a huge
advantage in life especially today in
this day and age with so much [ __ ] going
so fast and everybody wants to keep
everything going everything up and
everything I want to be the grace you
know the greatest multitask of all time
not me if I put my hundred percent into
what's in front of me I will destroy it
if I'm out here just multitasking this
[ __ ] I'm gonna half-ass everything I do
so that's it is the most important thing
the world of me is being focused at the
task at hand and it's getting harder and
harder to do that because there are so
many distractions and it's so easily -
it's so easy to distract yourself yes
you'll never have to be bored again with
these things in our pockets
no but the one thing I'm most scared of
in the world is losing losing touch with
the the best thing in the world
is is your mind your mindset how you can
picture yourself how you can focus how
you can drive how you can put yourself
in so many situations get out of it
because those headphones were listening
to those those phones that
we googled to find information there's
so many situations in my life where that
shit's not gonna help me it's not gonna
help me and you're able to just turn
that off so fast because I know please
help me
none of that stuff has ever helped me
mm-hmm none that stuff Sarah help me
would has helped me has been me alone
getting my [ __ ] together and being
accountable for who I'm not and who I
want to be stolen has helped me so you
get in you you get the opportunity to
become a Navy SEAL and then you end up
going through buds three times it's like
yeah lucky man unbelievable and the
stories of what that entailed are like
so vivid man unbelievable well I was uh
I was very fortunate to go through three
times and not in this a distich way in a
life changing growing way I found out so
much about myself through going through
that training three times and I went
through the hardest part of the training
three times you know after the first so
first phase is a crucible man and that's
where I was at for three times I spent
most of my time and buds in first phase
and the hell week in the hell weeks and
being in that grind and in that grind I
got time to examine myself I caught the
live autopsy and also examine other
people cuz I was really good about
putting people way above me because I
was I wasn't [ __ ]
I was never nobody so for me to be on
the same stage as these great wannabe
Navy SEALs and bus-train like my god you
guys are amazing I actually got here
with you all thank you so much for
allowing me into play but as I was there
for so long I got a really good chance
to sit back because now the cold waters
its water now it's not our code anymore
your mind starts to change they said get
in the water most people think about it
for you
it became my life so I started learning
that if you try to change your mindset
versus it being like oh my god this
sucks I became a professional blood
student so I wasn't gonna leave until I
graduated so I started realizing if this
is my home this is what I am I had to
always reset the bar
I had to reset my new norm there always
had to be a new norm so one thing we
don't do is we don't have a new norm my
new norm is you get up every [ __ ]
morning at 4 o'clock and you suffer
this is your new norm that became my new
[ __ ] life most people want to get out
of it I said now I [ __ ] this is
your new life this is who you are you
your new norm as you wake up and you
suffer and I started realizing if that's
my mentality
this should ain't hard anymore for her
your [ __ ] new normals you wake up
you're getting the [ __ ] cold water
you get a beer - this shit's [ __ ]
done whenever they say you're out you
get out so my new norm so I I do that
now today my new norm now is if I'm
doing the tour's in my run your new norm
now man is you [ __ ] or doing two
hundred [ __ ] miles